just before we get started i will say that
this video is sponsored by quincy 400.
for most presidents their long-term reputation
lives and dies upon what they did during their
administration herbert for example was a
great humanitarian now only remembered for a
much greater depression no one meanwhile seriously
remembers woodrow wilson for overhauling princeton
university heck even dwight d eisenhower is better
known for his two terms than winning goddamn world
war ii but occasionally you get a president whose
deeds before or after their administration are
central to their place in history of these perhaps
none is so fascinating as john quincy adams the
sixth president of the united states adams was
also the white house's first major disappointment
in a single term he failed to do anything much of
consequence existing mainly as a human punching
bag for his successor andrew jackson yet rather
than the pinnacle the presidency would turn out
to be a brief dip in his otherwise remarkable
life as secretary of state pre-presidency adams
helped shape america in profound ways in
his post-white house career he became one
of the most powerful anti-slavery voices in the
nation a mediocre ineffectual president who still
transforms the united states this is the life
of john quincy adams america's greatest failure
when john quincy adams was born in braintree
massachusetts later named quincy on july the
11th 1767 it was into a seemingly average family
his parents weren't incredibly rich or highly
connected and while his father was fiercely
interested in politics he wasn't exactly
a mover and shaker but of course we already know
there was nothing average about adams family his
dad was future founding father john adams his mum
future first lady abigail adams and that ensured
there would be nothing remotely average about
john quincy's upbringing things got moving in
1774 with the calling of the first continental
congress essentially a big convention dedicated
to discussing what a [ __ ] george iii was adams's
dad was one of their state's delegates but while
this was the family's first flirtation
with history it would be what came next
that really transformed their fortunes on april
19th 1775 some forgotten soldier at lexington
fired their gun during a tense standoff between
british forces and american militia it was the
opening of the american revolutionary war the shot
heard around the world it was also the starting
gun on john adams's high velocity career with his
dad running off to join the second continental
congress that spring john quincy always left to
witness the war unfold from his mother's side
like literally that summer abigail took her son to
the top of a nearby hill from where they could see
the distant carnage of the battle of bunker hill
the next few years the boy would frequently see
soldiers marching through his hometown then there
were the fears he felt for his dad on july the 4th
1776 john adams signed his name on the declaration
of independence one hour celebrated moment it was
at the time treason and adams was paralyzed by
the fear that the british might execute his dad
not that there was much space for airing these
fears at home always a hard woman abigail adams
had transformed by the war into a mother
determined to raise a future american leader
she would truck no emotions from her boy no
idleness nothing at all that most of us would
associate with childhood and that meant that john
quincy grew up faster than even other kids in this
turbulent era aged just 10 he was sent with his
dad on a dangerous diplomatic trip to europe on
which saw british ships stalk and harass their
vessel on a second voyage the following year the
boat sprang a leak barely making it to the spanish
coast getting to paris then required a grueling
two-month trek on mules at this time john quincy
was also taking on diplomatic responsibilities
like teaching the french minister to the united
states english or sitting in on meetings between
his dad and benjamin franklin it was as if john
and abigail were trying to fashion their son
into a machine for diplomacy a sort of nerdy
robocop built for geopolitics as abigail wrote
to her still prepubescent son these are the times
in which a genius would wish to live it is not
in the still calm of life or the repose
of a pacific station that great characters
are formed which was maybe why adam's
life in europe was as far from still
as it's possible to get over the years of the war
john quincy lived in holland and france spending
time in sweden and prussia he became fluent in
french passable and dutch age 14 he was appointed
secretary and translator to the u.s embassy
to russia in time he'd master seven languages
but his biggest moment came at the age of 16. in
1783 adams served as a secretary to the american
delegation in paris watching from up close as a
peace treaty was thrashed out with britain ending
the revolutionary war it was an invaluable insight
into international politics what adams would take
into his future diplomatic ventures but first the
teenage john quincy wanted to return to america
as he reached adulthood john quincy adams had
grown into a highly intelligent well-traveled
and well-read young man he also however had grown
into a neurotic mess an ill-tempered emotionally
cold egotist who most people instinctively
disliked in short the ideal combination for
professional success and personal misery first
the professional success back in the us john
quincy graduated harvard passed the bar and
began practicing law all by the age of 23. he
also found a side gig writing articles in support
of the new president's articles that soon brought
him to george washington's attention it probably
didn't hurt that washington's vice president was
john quincy's dad in 1794 the president appointed
him minister to the netherlands and adams returned
to europe okay so that's the amazing career what
about the personal misery for that we need to look
no further than adams's love life while in the
u.s john quincy had fallen spectacularly for a
local girl he'd even wanted to propose but then
abigail had told him that he needed to focus on
his career so adams broke off with the young
woman only to regret the decision immediately
and intensely in fact he regretted it so much that
when he met 22 year old louisa catherine in london
he didn't even hesitate before asking her to
marry him the daughter of an american expat and
an english woman louisa was intelligent creative
exactly the sort of things that most people would
want in a fiance the problem was adams wasn't most
people he actively refused to be in the same room
as louisa when she played music and could barely
stand talking to her they married in july 1797. by
the time louise became the first of only two
foreign-born first ladies the pair could go
literal weeks without speaking but that was still
many years away for now the young adams simply
kept up his diplomatic work becoming his dad's man
in prussia after john adams gained the presidency
then returning to america again when his dad lost
it not that this loss impacted adams own career
elected to the massachusetts state senate in 1802
adams was quickly promoted to one of the state's
two congressional senators massachusetts c was
controlled by the federalist party since his dad
had been a federalist the leadership assumed
adams was as safe about as they could make
but that assumption couldn't have been more
wrong in congress john quincy surprised
everyone by frequently siding not with his
dad's federalists but with their opponents
the democratic republicans this included weighty
stuff like the 1807 embargo act which blocked
trade with all foreign nations a brave attempt
to get britain to respect america's maritime
rights but one with the unfortunate side effect
of screwing over adams's home base of new england
yet adams voted for the measure feeling his
conscience would not allow him to do otherwise
in massachusetts though the federalists felt
that adams consciousness could kiss their butts
outraged at his betrayal they announced his
replacement before his term was even over five
days later adams resigned shortly after he was
spotted at the democratic republican convention
his switch to the enemy party now official
but while this mountain made him as popular
with federalists as a carolina reaper enema it
was also an excellent career move in the 1808
election democratic republican james madison
trounced his federalist rival he awarded john
quincy switch of allegiance with the job of u.s
minister to russia and so it was back to europe
back to a continent broken and bruised by the
napoleonic wars from his vantage point in saint
petersburg adams was able to witness france's
failed invasion of russia to take part in the
negotiations with britain that ended the war of
1812 to watch napoleon's collapse at waterloo
come 1817 john quincy was living in london with
more experiences under his belt the most managed
in a lifetime yet it would be the next seven
years that saw his greatest achievements of all
back home james monroe had just been elected
president and he had the perfect role lined
up for the worldly intelligent john quincy adams
he wanted adams to become his secretary of state
although on paper he was the perfect candidate
deep down adams was worried worried that monroe
had made the wrong choice worried that he'd be a
failure as he wrote to abigail he felt that the
president had overestimated not the goodness of
my intentions but the extent of my talents for a
man so egotistical he once called his own diaries
the most precious and valuable book ever written
by human hands such fears seem remarkable
an indication that adams really did sense
he might not be fit for high office and while
time and the highest office in the land would
eventually prove him right in 1817 the opposite
happened john quincy adams was about to become
perhaps the best secretary of state the u.s ever
had adams is genius in his ability to negotiate
under his watch vital treaties were signed that
changed america forever the most vital of these
the treaties with britain and spain at this point
remember adams had lived through two major wars
with britain and voted for legislation designed
to cuddle trade ties with london so he'd have
been forgiven for making his official stance
screw those limey douchebags but no instead
adams spearheaded the convention of 1818
which permanently set the u.s canadian border
along the 49th parallel all the way to the rocky
mountains with a ban on armaments along the border
this treaty helped diffuse 50 years of tensions
between london and washington ushering in a new
era in which redcoats weren't constantly trying
to burn down the white house more important
still though may have been the treaty with spain
signed in 1819 the treaty saw florida officially
handed to the united states and spain give up its
claims to territory north of latitude 42 degrees
since this included oregon county it set the
stage for yet further u.s expansion westward
in the future in return the southern border was
set with madrid's colony of new spain giving the
spaniards control of texas but since spain was
about to get booted out of what is now mexico
uncle sam wouldn't have to worry about keeping up
his end of the bargain for very long impressive
as these treaties were though perhaps adams's
biggest achievement was a speech which doesn't
even bear his name the monroe doctrine takes its
name from the president who first articulated it
but the idea was nearly all john quincy adams's
in a nutshell the doctrine told europe to forget
sailing across the atlantic to do more colonizing
the newly independent american nations would stay
independent and any attempt to say otherwise would
result in a star-spangled foot being inserted
up the old continent's backside at the time
this was a ballsy statement like scrappy doo
threatening to go 10 rounds with cujo the u.s
simply wasn't powerful enough to be bossing
multiple empires around but it was also a
sign of how the tides were shifting of how
the western hemisphere was turning towards the u.s
in decades to come the monroe doctrine would be
used to justify all sorts of unwelcome intrusions
in latin america but it's no doubt its unveiling
was a pivotal moment so that was john quincy's
career as his time as secretary of state drew
to a close while with the track record of three
major wins plus a minor victory professionalizing
the diplomatic service stacked together all this
made adams feel like it got a pretty good shot at
taking over from monroe when the president left
office the trouble was he wasn't the only one
as the election year of 1824 dawned it was on
a country that had dramatically changed the
federalist party heard collapsed male suffrage had
been expanded 18 of the 24 states now chose their
presidential electors by popular vote it would
in short be a watershed election one that would
fulfill john quincy's wildest dreams even as it
laid the groundwork for his political destruction
although only one party contested the 1824
election that doesn't mean there was only one
candidate alongside adams three other men all vied
for the top job each with their own bases of power
it was the fire brand house speaker henry clay
of kendaki the favorite of the elites william h
crawford but it was the outsider candidate that
would throw all of adams's hopes into disarray
the popular and populist tennessee general
andrew jackson from the get-go the race was
messy divided and as bitter as cyanide that summer
crawford was put forward under the old caucus
system selected not by voters but by congressmen
leaning on crawford's selection as undemocratic
massachusetts legislature instead nominated adams
down in kentucky the same thing happened with
henry clay but it was andrew jackson who put up
the most vigorous opposition putting on rallies
that made the pro adams faction's efforts look
like the class nerd's unattended birthday parties
because the class nerd is kind of what adams was
he was clever yes even brilliant but he was also
widely disliked the martin prince of presidential
politics there was no way in this era when the
popular vote actually mattered that cerebral adams
could win against a natural populist like jackson
when the results came it was clear john quincy's
presidential bid had failed while it left client
crawford eating his dust taking 30.9 percent of
the popular vote adams had only won new england
and new york jackson meanwhile had captured 11
states and 41.4 percent of the vote and you don't
need to be a john quincy style genius to know that
41 was a much higher number than 31. so this is it
then the moment when we reveal that all of this
has just been an incredibly long intro to our
andrew jackson biography well not exactly see
jackson may have taken the most votes and states
but his delicate count at the electoral college
was 99 to 32 short of a majority that meant the
12th amendment kicking in meaning the house would
now decide the outcome on a one-state one-vote
basis and with clay prevented from moving to the
second round that meant vital delegates were still
in play on february 9 1825 the house held its
contingent election disgusted by jackson clay
convinced all of his states to back adams he and
former federalists then began pressuring others
to back the sensible john quincy over the fiery
andrew jackson incredibly the campaign worked on
the first ballot 13 states threw their support
to adams giving him the simple majority needed
to be declared winner john quincy adams would now
become the sixth president of the united states
to call jackson outraged would be to underestimate
how volcanically his rage erupted on hearing the
results the general accused adams and clay
of conspiring to make a corrupt bargain a
charge adam seemed to confirm when he
appointed clay his secretary of state
while historians today don't think that any
shady bargain existed the optics were still
terrible for anyone even remotely pro-jackson
it appeared the election had been stolen even
adam seemed to recognize this acknowledging to
the american people i am less possessed of your
confidence in advance than any of my predecessors
yet ultimately it wouldn't matter as he assumed
the presidency john quincy adams did so with a
bold plan for the future one that would be so
transformative so beneficial that andrew jackson
would soon be forgotten yeah about that as adams
was about to discover being president is not
the same as being an old timey king you need
support in both chambers broad following among
the public the sixth president had none of these
things and now adams was going to find out
just how hard ruling as a lame duck really is
there can be few u.s presidents with such a
stark gap between what they intended to achieve
and what they actually managed to do when john
quincy adams entered the white house it was with
an ambitious program designed to wed the states
into a true nation with a vast internal market and
a strong executive adams wanted to construct roads
and canals to connect americans to standardize
weights and measures to build universities and
observer trees and dispatch survey teams to map
everything the continent had to offer yet while
he would see modest success with construction
projects including the lake erie canal mostly
what adams would see would be endless failure
1820s america didn't see an early new
deal in his plans for massive public works
no what they saw were attempts to drain power from
states and pump it directly to washington more to
the point they also saw a president elected in
a contentious manner suddenly acting like he was
the messiah of government reform but rather than
the messiah congress would treat adams as a very
naughty boy from the get-go the sixth president
was hampered in all his goals spurned even by
former supporters for two years things just about
held together but then 1826 rolled around and
adam's world fell apart first his father always
his staunchest supporter died from a heart attack
with his dad gone adams lost the one person he
could truly count on yet his personal isolation
would soon be compounded by a second disaster
in the midterm elections that year jacksonians
took control of congress determined to block
everything adams tried to do in the two years
since the contingent election jackson hadn't
remotely mellowed instead launching an endless
campaign against the president all while building
an election-winning machine with congress now
solidly against him adams would spend the rest
of his presidency unable to do anything but
helplessly watch as his ambitions crumbled to
dust there were the delegates adams wanted to
send to panama for a meeting of american nations
only for congress to block their funding or the
tariff package congress forced him to authorize
that was so unpopular it became known as the
tariff of abominations even when adams tried to
do rights such as supporting the rights of creek
indians to have their territory respected congress
still rejected him now this doesn't mean adams was
an actively bad president stacked next to him
james buchanan it looks positively great but it
does mean that he became a mediocre president
one whose term would be defined by inertia
drift and ever shrinking expectations against
this backdrop the 1828 election was almost a
mercy killing now at the head of the newly formed
democratic party andrew jackson was back and he
was ready for vengeance that winter the general
won a crushing victory taking 55.5 percent of the
vote and dominating the electoral college like his
father before him john quincy was now officially a
one-term president and just like his father before
him adam's left under a grumpy cloud refusing to
attend his successors inauguration but while this
would be the end of most presidential bios barring
a quick paragraph explaining how they died adams's
biography still has a final chapter because after
a disappointing presidency his career was going
to have one last glorious high in the coming years
john quincy adams was going to reinvent himself
as nothing less than the conscious of his nation
in the 1840s there was nothing guaranteed
to silence the house faster than
old man eloquent standing up to speak as
the 70-something john quincy adams rose a
hush would descend representatives from
the democrats and whigs alike would wait
in respectful quiet to see what their elder had
to say but this respect wasn't just due to adams
age or the fact that he'd once been president
rather it was due to his long and extraordinary
post-white house career after he lost the
election john quincy had gone into retirement
moping miserably around massachusetts as the
jacksonian revolution got underway but then some
neighbors had pressured him to run for congress
and adams had won entering the house in december
of 1831. at the time many thought it beneath
him a former president reduced to just one of
hundreds of representatives as adams put it though
no person could be degraded by serving the people
and serve was exactly what adams intended to
do over 16 plus years john quincy would forge
a second career speaking out forcefully against
aggressive expansion against the war with mexico
but his greatest most lasting achievement would
be his opposition to slavery of the first 12
presidents the only ones who didn't own enslaved
people were john quincy and his dad and while john
quincy would never publicly declare himself an
abolitionist his actions in the house sure suggest
that he was leaning that way his biggest battle
was against the gag rule which banned debate on
any petition concerning slavery convinced this was
an insult to the first amendment adams launched
what can only be described as a crusade against it
from 1836 he violated the rule whenever he could
attempting to get anti-slavery petitions read into
record risking the wrath of southerners for years
it looked like a fool's errand but you know
that old quote often misattributed to gandhi
first they ignore you then they laugh at you then
you win well adams kept going until he won in 1844
the house relented voting to end the gag rule by
then adams was already fighting slavery on other
fronts in 1841 he'd gone before the supreme
court to argue the amistad case on behalf
of slaves who'd mutineed aboard a spanish ship
only to be captured by american sailors adams
argument was a blistering denunciation of slavery
is against american founding principles saying the
moment you come to the declaration of independence
that every man has a right to life and liberty
an inalienable right this case is decided i ask
nothing more in behalf of these unfortunate men
than this declaration he won the case and the
former slaves went free yet while john quincy
would spend his latter years chipping away
at the edifice of slavery he sadly wouldn't
live to see the whole rotten system collapse on
february 21 1848 adams had just finished making a
passionate speech in the house when he suffered a
massive stroke carried to a sofa in the speaker's
office he died two days later his last words were
this is the end of earth but i am content john
quincy adams passed away at the age of 80 leaving
behind a career so long and complex that even now
it's impossible to neatly summarize on the one
hand his time as president was a disappointment
a single term in which little was accomplished
on the other though his careers both pre and
post-presidency were seemingly sprinkled with gold
dust charmed things that glittered brightly next
to the dreary grave is one term it's fascinating
isn't it how ill-equipped we often are to deal
with a narrative that subverts our expectations
that doesn't climax with the presidency but with
the roles of secretary of state and representative
roles we assume are somehow lesser but the life of
the sixth president shows us this isn't the case
the presidential rankings can never capture all
the good and bad of a person's life in summing
up john quincy adams then perhaps we should
instead look to the words of his wife louisa who
once described him as exasperating tendentious
self-absorbed and yet in the end magnificent i
hope you found today's video interesting if you
did please do hit that like button below don't
forget to subscribe and thank you for watching